ARUN NAGARAJAN: Hello, and
welcome to another exciting
episode of Google
Developers Live.
My name is Arun Nagarajan,
and we're streaming here
from New York City.
We're today gonna try an
exciting new series called
Apps Script Crash Course.
And the topic we're gonna
dive deep into today is
ContentService.
So let's take a look.
Let's take a look at what
ContentService can do, what
it's all about.
Before we're gonna dive all into
ContentService, one of
the things I want to do is walk
you through where does
ContentService fit?
So let's take a look at the
slides a little bit here.
So, one of the things that we
want to take a look at here in
the slides is the high-level
details of all the different
execution methods
of Apps script.
As you can see, there are seven
different execution
contexts for Apps script.
Obviously, you can run it right
from the script editor,
custom functions in
spreadsheets, web apps,
gadgets in sites, container
extensions, time-driven
triggers, container-specific
triggers.
These are things like onEdit,
onFormSubmit, things like that.
So quite a few different ways
you can run these Apps Script.
The one that I've highlighted
there is called web apps.
So web apps, as you probably
have already seen, you can do
a lot of really interesting
things with.
You can actually accept
requests, respond with UI, and
all sorts of good things
like that.
And what I've done here is
actually taken web apps and
blown it out into other ways
you could output that.
So with a web app, you can
display user interface, UI app
using the GUI builder and other
things as well-- this is
sort of a programmatic way of
building an application--
or HTML service, which allows
you to bring your own HTML,
JavaScript, and CSS and really
build a much more bespoke UI
that you want.
What we're here to talk about
today is ContentService.
So this is sort of where
ContentService really sits.
It's a mode of output
for web apps.
So hopefully this slide kind of
gives you a sense for where
within the Apps Script
ecosystem
ContentService fits in.
So ContentService is a type
of output for web apps.
OK.
So what does ContentService
look like?
It's actually really simple.
So, within a couple of lines
you can build a very simple
ContentService app.
You can have it outputting
a simple 'Hello World'.
various other text types like
JSON, XML, atom, and we'll take
a at look a few other
interesting examples
today as well.
You can accept request
through GET and POST.
And it's got a very similar
authentication model to an
HTML service.
So, I should really
say the same.
You can deploy it as yourself.
You can deploy it as the
person accessing the
application.
You can have it be anonymous
as well, which is great.
So you can really build
something pretty useful for a
lot of different scenarios.
And in essence, it really allows
you to build an API on
top of Apps Script that exposes
your Google data
securely, or other spreadsheet
information that you may want
to have available as an API.
And we'll see some examples of
how this all makes sense in a
real-world scenario.
So, let's just take a quick look
at a very simple example.
So I'm just gonna go ahead.
Open up a script editor.
Go to script.google.com.
Start a blank project.
And this should give a sense
for how you build a very
simple ContentService
application.
I'll just say function doGet.
I won't accept any parameters
for now.
And I'll just say
ContentService.c
reateTextOutput, 'hello
GDL', and that's it.
Oh, I have to return it.
I always forget that.
So that's the code that when you
call it from an external
URL invocation, it'll return
a simple piece of text.
So let's just roll it out.
So let's just say gdl
test, and I'll--
so the same deployment
mechanisms apply.
So you have to go into--
let me save it.
You got to have a version
specified.
Save a version.
Go under Publish, Deploy
as web app.
You have to pick the
project version.
In this case, I'm just gonna
execute for myself.
I'm gonna deploy, copy
the code, and run it.
And you'll see 'hello GDL'.
OK.
Very simple text response that
allows you to just ensure that
you're doing the right thing as
far as the deployment, the
authentication, and make sure
you're calling the right URL.
So one thing to note is that the
content that is responded
from ContentService is not
sanitized by Caja or other
tools we use internally that
HTML service goes through.
So, in order to make sure that
it's still secure, what we do
do is redirect the service
to a different domain,
googleusercontent.com.
So if you're using cURL or other
mechanisms, ensure that
you're following redirect so
that you're able to get at the
content that you're trying to
return, not just stuck in the
original
script.google.com/exeurls.
OK.
So just to really illustrate
that, if you go and look at
the URL, the URL
script.google.com/macros and
the whole URL that you're used
to from HTML service and other
different deployment mechanisms,
the ultimate end
URL ends in
googleuserscontent.com.
OK.
So that's a very
simple example.
So let's take a look
at what's possible,
what else is possible.
So here are some other
examples of some more
sophisticated examples.
So the first one--
and we'll actually kind
of see this in our
documentation as well--
is a very simple parse an
existing XML feed and then
replace it with some information
that it may be
tucked away and create
a new RSS feed and
respond with that.
So this may be a little
hard to see here.
So let me actually go and find
it in our documentation site,
which is exactly where
I pulled it up from.
So here's our ContentService
documentation site.
So you can see that off the left
navigation you can pick
Serving Content as the option.
And I'll show you the exact
example that we're talking
about here.
So a lot of you folks that are
in the tech industry may be a
big fan of xkcd like I am.
And one of the cool things that
they do is they tuck away
some really interesting
commentary and notes in the
Alt Tag of an image,
the actual comic.
So in this example what we're
doing is we're taking an
existing RSS feed, replacing the
RSS feed with interesting
data that we're able to parse
out using a simple regular
expression, and then return
it as another RSS feed.
So a simple processing pipeline
that I think is
interesting.
Another example is the ability
to return JSON data.
So we'll kind of dive deep
into these examples.
So here you can see that
it takes a request--
let me zoom in some more so you
can see all the details.
Here it's taking in a request
object that contains two
parameters, start and end, and
it's actually going into the
calendar app and finding to see
if you have any meetings
during that day.
So a very simple free/busy
look-up type application here.
So you can actually expose this
to other folks saying
whether I am free between these
days or not, between
this time or not.
And all it's returning
is a true or false.
So there's really not a lot of
sensitive data being leaked.
So you can actually make this
available for interesting
third-party applications,
if that makes sense.
Great.
So let's go back.
And now let's talk about some
other things that we're gonna
talk about.
So what I want to do during this
session is really walk
you through a few different
examples of what are some of
these things that
we can build.
So, very first thing I'm gonna
show is an RSS example.
So take something that is very
day to day and expose that as
an RSS, which allows you to
display that in very different
places, like a Google Site
or Google Reader or other
third-party tools that may
accept RSS or atom data.
A JSON example.
So you're able to take a
spreadsheet, make that act
like a database, and expose
the data around it to a
third-party application, a
mobile application or another
application.
We'll talk about
JSONP briefly.
So JSONP is the way you can
have a third-party website
that executes JavaScript on
the client side within a
browser, access data from
a third-party domain.
The other option for
this is CORS, cross
origin resource sharing.
That is not something
we support today.
So JSONP is the way you will be
accessing data between two
different sites.
And then we'll show some
interesting examples around
other MIME types that may
make sense as well.
So this should hopefully be
interesting where we download
vCard information
about a contact.
OK.
So those are the four demos
that we will show.
And we'll go through
it fairly quickly.
And after the session I'll
make sure all the code is
available in my GitHub
site as well.
So let's take a look at the
first example, RSS.
Go back.
So I've written the code for a
lot of this already, so just
to expedite our demos here.
What we'll show here first
is the RSS example.
So what this is going
to do is--
the doGet entry point--
is all it's gonna do is to
evaluate a template and
respond back with the content
produced from that template.
So one thing that might be
curious here that's worthwhile
noting is that we're using some
of the capabilities of
HTML Service within
ContentService.
This is actually
quite powerful.
So HTML Service has the
templating capabilities.
There's nothing about it that
restricts it to just HTML.
So you can actually use the
templating liabilities with
the angle bracket forceprint
angle bracket question mark
equals and all these other
variations within the
ContentService output mode.
And here's the actual
template.
So as you can see here, we have
a very simple template.
RSS is the sort of the starting
tag and then has a
channel within it.
So anyone that's seen an RSS
feed, the actual raw RSS feed,
they'll be able to see
all these details.
We have a title that's static.
And then we have something that
enumerates over all the
different items that I may
have in my response.
So what are we enumerating
over here?
In this case, we're doing a
Gmail app call to get all the
inbox resident and enumerate
over them.
So this is interesting because
what you could potentially do
is let's say you have a shared
inbox for a help desk or for
some sort of a team inbox or
something along those lines,
you can actually have that
available within your
organization in a gadget
using Google Sites.
So let's just quickly take a
look to this code, and then
I'll show you what
the end result of
this might look like.
So I'm going through all the
threads, finding all the
messages within those threads.
Then in a single loop, I'm just
finding the first message
for the subject, getting the
body from the most recent
email, getting an ID so that I
can potentially link to it in
the future, and then also a date
so that that's useful for
RSS readers.
OK.
So these tags--
you may be familiar with
HTML service--
all it does is essentially
allows us to intersperse
server-side JavaScript within
our content such that the
template is executed with the
dynamic data that it produces.
And then you'll see these
forceprint as well--
or I should say just print--
which instead of evaluating
it and then trying to do
something with that data, it
just returns it as a literal
after it's evaluated.
So loop through all my threads
and produce these for the x
number of threads I may have.
All right.
So let's publish this.
I may already have
it published.
I'll just copy the URL.
So this is the URL of this.
And for now, I'm just gonna
make this available
anonymously.
If you're running it within a
Google Apps account, you can
have it available to just your
domain, which is, I think, a
great way to deploy
this as well.
So what I'll do now is go to
sites.google.com under my account.
Create a simple site, GDL.
It'll ask me for this
real quick.
Create the site.
Google that site.
You should put a number.
That'll help.
OK.
Create a site.
Cool.
So what this allows us to do
is essentially find a great
way for me to deploy
this RSS feed.
Google Reader's another
way you can have this
available as well.
But in this scenario, what I'm
getting at is a way you can
distribute this within
your team internally.
Go to More Gadgets.
Here's the gadget
for RSS feed.
Select it.
Paste my URL.
So this is the exact URL that we
deployed the endpoint onto.
Hit OK.
Save.
And there it is.
So that you could have an
internal site to your team--
or in this case it's
a public site--
where an email inbox is
being read-- so let me
go back to my email--
an email inbox is being read
and displayed as a very
simplistic RSS feed.
So it's a great way to
kind of have your--
let's say you have an inbox for
marketing news, you may
have an inbox for support
desk, things like that.
You're able to actually have
that surface up in an
interesting manner in a site or
other RSS gadgets that you
may be using.
So this is an example where
Apps Script allows you to
deploy content, such as RSS, in
a secure manner within your
organization.
Great.
So now let's do something
a little bit different.
So let's actually dive into
using-- so in this case it's
not quite an API.
It's really another deployment
mechanism, like HTML.
It happens to be under
a ContentService.
RSS is a type of XML protocol.
So what we'll do now is actually
pretend as if we have
another application that is
trying to access data from a
spreadsheet or another internal
mechanism like a
contact database, something
along those lines were Apps
Script is great at getting at
that data very quickly.
Couple of lines of code, you're
able to grab your
spreadsheet data.
Couple lines of code, you're
able to grab data from your
address book and things
like that, right.
So what we're gonna do is we're
gonna actually pretend
as if we have a very simple
inventory database.
So, IT help desk is a simple
scenario that I
came up with here.
Let's say that I am working
at a small department.
And we have an inventory of a
few things, Chromebooks and
MacBook Airs and
Dell monitors.
I just made up a few SKUs and
quantities and whatnot.
And the goal is to expose this
data in a nice API such that I
could potentially consume it
from, let's say, an iPhone
application.
Very similar capabilities
apply to do Android.
You may have an App Engine
application calling the same
API from URL fetch on
the server side.
Anywhere where you can call JSON
across domain boundaries,
this is a great way
to expose that.
What I also have here--
excuse me--
what I also have here is a
simple script, which uses a
lot of the templates that we
provide today, which allows
you to turn a row
into an object.
So I just kind of copied
that exact template.
So all these functions should
look very familiar.
Get rows data, get objects,
normalize headers, this is
exactly from the template
that we provide.
And what I've done is
basically open the
spreadsheet, get the range that
I care for, get all the
rows as an object, and then
just output that in a very
simple call with the
MIME type of JSON.
OK.
So we'll dissect this code in
a little bit, but let's kind
of see what's on the
client side.
So what we've done
so far is an API.
And we'll just take a look at
what the API looks like.
I just copy this and paste
it into a window.
You'll see that it's
just JSON.
OK.
It's an array of objects, items
within a larger array.
So now let's go to the
client-side code.
What I have here--
I'm by no means a iOS developer,
but just whip
something quickly together.
What I have here is a very
simple application that has a
table view.
Hopefully that font
is decent enough.
All I have here is a simple
table view which is populated
based on a URL call.
It is parsed as a JSON object.
And then I have a table cell
for the x number of objects
that are returned.
And I'm just mapping the item
name and the quantity into it.
OK.
So let's run this.
So this will fire up
the simulator.
Sitting over there, I think.
May take a second.
There it goes.
And there's the data, right.
Very simple API.
And I'm able to see all the
items I have in my inventory
spreadsheet and the
current quantity.
So let's do a quick test.
So let me actually go
into my spreadsheet.
And I'll say let me
insert a new row.
I'll say I got some speakers--
three speakers, no color, and
Scott owns those as well.
And I'll also say five
of my headphones
have been given out--
or only five of them
are remaining.
OK.
No need to save.
It's all in the cloud, great
feature of spreadsheets.
And I'm gonna hit the
Refresh button.
And you can see that this native
application was able to
grab that data very quickly
and reflect that in a nice
mobile-friendly UI.
So you have the speakers
that are now available.
The headphones have
been decremented.
Very simple application, but if
you can imagine since this
is a native application, you
can have the offline cache
enabled, you can have this
available on an Android phone,
and so on as well.
And we'll talk about Android
in a lot more detail in
another GDL.
So that's the idea here.
So, you're able to expose data
within your spreadsheets as a
JSON API, which makes it
incredibly easy for other
third-party applications to
parse it and then stick it
into a nice UI that is
applicable to the front end.
So this is what I was mentioning
when I talked about
exposing your data via an API
and build that API with Apps
Script itself.
Great.
So, one of the things that
a lot of the seasoned web
developers have probably already
gathered is that you
can just call JSON APIs
across domains.
So this is something I
mentioned briefly.
So let's say you have a web app
running within App Engine
or some other hosting service,
that domain will not be
script.google.com.
You cannot make cross-origin
JSON calls using AJAX.
There's a new protocol that's
coming out called CORS,
C-O-R-S. We're looking at it.
And hopefully we'll have some
more investigation that we'll
do on that front and
give you an update.
But for now, the way you have
that cross communicate between
those two different domains is
a technology called JSONP.
JSONP is basically
JSON padding.
And the padding is basically the
callback function that is
executed on the client side when
the response comes back.
So that's the way you would
use an API built on Apps
Script within a browser, so
within a web UI, if you're
building that.
So let's go take a look at what
that might look like.
So, I kept this one
very simple.
So let's say we have some data,
in this case the result
is 'hello world'.
This could be an object.
This could be data
from your Gmail.
This could be data from a drive,
file, what have you.
In this case I kept it very
simple and static.
And what's interesting here--
let me break this up a little
bit, copy this out,
so let's say var
content equal to this--
is we're not just returning
the content directly.
We're also taking in a prefix
from the request and padding
that response with that.
So this parentheses essentially
says when this
returns, treat this as
JavaScript and execute it.
So jQuery and a lot of other
libraries know how
to deal with this.
And we'll show that
in a second.
And then once I've done this,
once the content is decorated,
I just return it as
a JSON MIME type.
OK.
So it's still JSON.
There's no MIME type
for JSONP.
And just while I'm here, I'll
also note that this MIME type
class has a really nice
auto-complete.
So you can just say
contentservice.mimetype and it
gives you all the different
capabilities that you have.
The default is text.
We already showed how we
can use RSS and JSON.
For JSONP, you stick
with JSON.
And we'll show some other
examples as well with text.
OK.
Great.
So, I will save this.
I already have a deployed
version, so I'll
just play with that.
So in order to show this, I need
to have a UI running on
another domain.
And for sake of simplicity, I
use a tool called jsFiddle.
Lot of you may have
heard of this.
Very simple tool.
So I'm just gonna
get rid of this.
And so, all that allows you to
do is paste in some HTML, see
the preview, and you can inject
it with JavaScript and
CSS that you may want to bring
in to really quickly test it.
So what they do is when you
hit Save, it's actually
running it off of
their servers.
And you're able to very quickly
test your code without
having to spin up a server
to host this.
And it's all available
on any browser.
So, jsFiddle.net,
a great tool.
You don't even have to login
to test the basic stuff.
So what I'm gonna do-- and you
can see that I'm loading in
jQuery here.
And what I have is a very simple
header called Welcome.
And I'm gonna paste in some
interesting JavaScript.
And let me zoom in
here just so--
I'm zooming on this side.
I'll zoom in here.
OK.
So all I have here is a jQuery
function that says when the
document is ready, go
call this service.
And in jQuery, the way you say
it's a JSONP is this prefix
equal the question mark.
If your URL ends with a question
mark, that's how you
tell jQuery that it's
a JSONP call.
And just make that with
the padding wrapper.
And jQuery takes care
of all that stuff.
It actually makes up a unique
padding server call-- a
padding method name calls with
that-- and then also ensures
that things are not cached
inappropriately, and all sorts
of good stuff.
And then you don't even have
to describe a separate
callback function.
You can just say, OK, when it's
back, just give me the
data, and I'll go with it.
So it actually unpacks the data
such that it only gets
the results and not the
callback function.
So what do I mean by that?
So if you can see here, we're
returning this sort of
padding around it.
And jQuery's really good
at just getting
to the actual results.
So let's actually run this.
And you can see that thing
because of the redirect,
things get a little funky.
It shows it twice.
Might be a little issue
with jsFiddle.
But you get the idea.
You're able to very quickly
grab data from Google Apps
Script that's outputting
JSONP and use it in
your own web apps.
OK.
So great way to add a little
bit more dynamicness, a bit
more interactiveness
to your web apps
using Google Apps Script.
Great.
So far we've talked about RSS.
We've talked about JSON to use
in a mobile app, JSONP to use
in a web app.
And we'll actually show one
last thing around vCards.
vCards are basically a protocol
that allows you to
export contacts that are
friendly for address book
applications.
So, an example is the one that
comes with a Mac OS.
The contacts application gives
you a really nice directory
style look.
Windows has something as well.
vCard is a really interesting
export option for a lot of
different directory and contact
management tools.
So what I've done is what if
we have a very simple--
let me go back to
find this guy.
There it is.
OK.
Cool.
So, what I have is in my inbox,
I have a contact.
I wasn't feeling creative
so I just added myself.
So you can just see I have one
contact with my email address.
And I made a phone number
and whatnot.
And in my example, what I'm
gonna do is grab a contact.
Again, I'm gonna do the
evaluation of the template.
But in this case, I'm going to
bind that template with the
contact object, get the final
output, and then return it.
But don't just return it, make
it available through a file--
download as file method call
and give it a name.
There is actually a hidden gem
within the API which allows
you to take any content you
have and give it a content
disposition header which makes
the browser say, OK, it's told
me that it wants to be available
in the file system,
the host machine.
Rather than the browser trying
to render it, it becomes a
downloadable file and the
normal operating system
invocation procedures kick in.
So it's great.
So it really allows you do some
pretty interesting things
with things like CSVs and
other interesting output
formats that you can cook
up pretty easily.
So let's take a look at what
a vCard looks like.
If you just go to Wikipedia,
lot of good
details on the protocol.
It's actually pretty sparse as
far as a protocol might go.
It just says begin vCard, a
bunch of name value pairs with
something separated by double
semicolons, and end vCard.
So, it's not like XML.
It's not like JSON.
It's its own little format.
And it's something that, I
think, has become standard
over the years.
OK.
So, what I've done is
basically copied
something like that.
And again, I've used the
template mechanism.
So I felt lazy and just kind
of punched in the same
property in a couple
different fields.
But you can see that you can
really populate a lot of
different fields
pretty easily.
And again, this contact today,
I'm just picking up one that
is hard coded.
You can theoretically have
something where an email
address is passed in through the
URL, and you're actually
picking that up individually
and making that
available as a vCard.
OK.
So, I make this contact object
that I read through the Google
Apps Script code base available
into the template.
That's what this line does.
That means I can do
contact.fullname here.
And ultimately, I'll get
the output that I want.
So let's take a look.
If I go to Publish, Deploy as
web app, copy this guy.
And just to kind of show you,
there is just one Arun
Nagarajan in here.
That's sort of the default one
that Apple adds into the
operating system.
So I'm gonna call this URL.
There's no UI to this.
Imagine this as a service
invocation where you may pass
in a parameter into it.
In this case, I just kept
it really simple.
I call it.
Again, no UI is shown.
Chrome shows me that there's
something available that I
should click on.
Probably hard to see.
It says contactcar.vcf And that
name, again, comes from
what I specified here.
I could have made this
a bit more dynamic.
I could have just used
arunnagarajan.vcf.
And going back here, if I click
on this, again, Chrome
doesn't do anything
at that point.
It says you said it was a
download as file call, so the
Apple address book comes in.
I add this contact.
And there it is.
All the different
things came in.
If I have some synchronization
rules with it and on my mobile
device, this will
work seamlessly.
So really allows you to provide
data that's sometimes
locked in behind Google
Apps such as contacts
and calendar entries.
vCal is another popular
format.
So ContentService allows you to
provide this sort of export
facility when that makes sense
for your application.
So, in this example I just
picked vCard because it was
simple enough, and it made
sense on my laptop.
But vCal is a really popular
extension type for--
or ICS is another one that
Outlook uses, I think.
So, really very easy for you
to build your own little
export and interaction mechanism
to all these
different applications using
content service.
So hope you found this
interesting.
And I'll post all this code
up on GitHub very soon.
And hope to see a lot of
interesting applications that
you may be building with
ContentService.
Thank you very much.